hydrogen is the universe's most abundant
element it's everywhere it's in
anything it's number one on the periodic
table but actually getting it and using
it as a form of clean energy has been
very tough for the last 30 years a lot
of big companies around the world have
been trying to figure out how to make
hydrogen attainable use it as a power
source for a fuel cell as a stationary
energy source a way to power buildings
it hasn't really worked out up to this
point but the last few years things are
beginning to
[Music]
change excitement is building up
specifically around green
[Music]
hydrogen this is a way of making
hydrogen that uses zero carbon inputs
and produces no emissions other than
oxygen in the US nearly all of the
hydrogen used in oil refining food
processing and other industrial
processes is considered gray this means
it is extracted from natural gas using
processes that generate carbon dioxide
if green hydrogen can be used at Large
Scale instead of gray hydrogen this
would make it a powerful tool against
climate change an unlimited source of
energy and a very lucrative business
internationally we're in Rochester New
York at Plug Power which wants to be one
of the leaders in this new emerging
techn technology manufacturing both fuel
cells which can power a vehicle or
generate electricity on a stationary
system and also making
electrolyzers devices that take water
and electricity and make hydrogen to
power those fuel cells and we're
speaking with Dan oconnell here at the
gigafactory that pluged runs and tell me
a little bit about what we're looking at
here this is a an electrolyzer uh and
what does the electrolyzer do exactly
how does this work this is an
electrolyzer and this is a 1 megawatt
unit and what this means is we can put a
megawatt of power into it and make 420
kg of hydrogen what we do is we put
electricity in we put purified water in
the Catalyst inside splits apart the
hydrogen and oxygen in water and we
capture that hydrogen and use it to fuel
vehicles depending upon the capacity of
the hydrogen on board storage inside the
vehicle but they usually use around 20
kgs so you could probably fill about 20
Vehicles off of one megawatt
electrolyzer or you can think of it as
like 400 standard sedan Vehicles next to
you we have uh the fuel cell the fuel
cell stack what is this doing yeah you
can think about the electrolyzer
splitting the water into hydrogen and
oxygen what in requiring power here we
want to take that hydrogen and turn it
back into water by combining with oxygen
and thereby generating electricity and
use that electricity to do some work for
us
plug pow technology supplies hydrogen
for a number of applications including
as a fuel for stationary energy
generation and fuel for trucks but the
company's primary Market is Material
Handling in the form of hydrogen powered
forklifts Plug Power says about 65,000
forklifts are being powered by their
hydrogen at large companies such as
Amazon Walmart and Home Depot so a
forklift driver will drive up to a pump
to just like you do today make a couple
of connections and once those
connections are made you'll be able to
put a kilogram of hydrogen on board the
forklift and be able to run for 8 hours
and the hydrogen's coming out in what
form is it is it liquid is it is it gas
no it comes out as gas at 350 bar or
5,000 PSI we take the water off and when
we get all the data off every time it
refuels we monitor everything going on
with that stack inside of that fuel cell
unit to be able to determine what's
going on
we can predict life we can predict
component failures so it's really a
wealth of data that we get every single
time it refills when did the transition
really happen where you started to see
uh fuel cell hydrogen fuel cell powered
uh forklifts replace other types of of
of Technologies yeah about eight or nine
years ago we started a small Fleet at
Amazon and we had half of them with
batteries and half of them with fuel
cells the forklift drivers love the fuel
cell ones because what talked about the
power the range and the recharge time so
the fuel cells started to win out we've
seen probably around a 10% efficiency
Improvement at those warehouses where
we've converted over to fuel cell
another big player in the green hydrogen
race is a company most people would
probably not expect cumins the world's
largest diesel engine maker its clean
tech division is known as accelera and
we had the chance to visit its Canadian
operations in massaga Ontario at this
facility we actually have a number of
buildings the building that we're in
right now is a building we kind of refer
to as the fuel cell building or the fuel
cell Technology Building in this
particular building we do have a small
uh manufacturing cell that makes fuel
cells uh for General use in in various
industry as well as we develop the next
generation of fuel cells we have a large
R&D component to the folks that work
here about 30 years of History we tried
to capture in this small Museum and what
you're seeing here Alan across the
shelving is a progression of fuel cell
techn ology development that started off
way back in in the mid
1990s when we became first of all a test
station company that was building test
stations which people who were
developing fuel cells would need and
then we started to test people's fuel
cells until we finally ourselves decided
to go into the fuel cell business with
special focus on commercial vehicles so
we were not a fuel cell for passenger
car company we were a fuel cell for
commercial vehicle company as
hydrogenics and in the shelving units
here you see a number of years the 2000s
the early 2000s in these days we were
making fuel cells that when they lasted
an hour or a day we'd pop champagne
bottles if you will so here at this
facility um you're developing uh
high-powered uh fuel cell Power Systems
and electrolyzers but on the fuel cell
stack the fuel cell motor or engine I
guess if you want to call it um you're
you're developing something that would
be very powerful powerful enough to
actually operate a Class 8 semi TR um
tell us a a little bit about what we're
looking at right here what is this unit
exactly yeah this is this is a powerful
one paired with its brother another one
just like this so it's twin I will say
this is our fourth generation fuel cell
which really shows the commitment that
Commons and accelera have had to
continuing to develop this technology
over time we started with our first
generation of fuel cells and second and
third in the 30 the 40 the 45 kilowatt
spaces those were low pressure
technology mhm as we advaned the
technology what we found was that we
needed to move to a variable pressure
which allows for more power density this
is a 150 kilowatt stack and as I
mentioned it will be paired with another
we're taking a modular platform approach
um to have 300 kilow of power to
commercialize um the the system for uh
heavy duty Vehicles CL state in North
America obviously you know Cummins is is
a giant in the trucking industry it's
the world's largest uh diesel engine
manufacturer is it is a little curious
that it's also pivoting into something
like hydrogen fuel cell which would seem
to be a competing technology eventually
with its diesel tech we actually see the
diesel technology as an enabler to get
to more Advanced Technologies because
we're leveraging the innovation of cumin
which is a company that's over 100 years
old we have significant experience in
terms of understanding applications and
Duty Cycles and how the products work in
the real market and and then we take
that and the system integration uh
skills we apply to the hydrogen to the
hydrogen fuel cell so we actually think
that the core technology is a huge
enabler as to why we're able to be
successful in the long term with our
destination zero strategy to see some of
accel's hydrogen trucks being worked on
and driven on public roads we toured its
facility in West Sacramento California
here at the West Sacramento facility we
do powertrain integration and we focus
on fuel cell powertrains so we install
fuel cells we install batteries Motors
everything to make the trucks run as a
fuel cell vehicle uh and then we do
testing out of this facility and we do
support for service and validation so
the range we're hoping to get it varies
by uh application but when we look at
longall Trucking for example um we're
targeting at least 500 Miles preferably
even 6 or 700 miles in the long run
maybe after 2030 but in the near term we
know we can get 450 mil in in a trucking
application a class8 truck that's really
exciting because there are battery
Vehicles Class A trucks that can get
around 300 to 400 miles but when you put
the the full weight and the full drive
cycle that these trucks are going to be
put into uh they they don't get 450 Mi
contrary to what some battery electric
vehicles might say and so for those
really intense applications 450 Mi is a
really big deal for a zero emission
powertrain in addition to longdistance
trucking acceler is also involved with
hydrogen powered trains it already has a
number of clean trains running in Europe
in a partnership with olem and recently
it helped power the first Hydrogen train
in North
America this is what we call in FCC a
fuel cell composition this fuel cell
composition also goes in pairs there are
two that are mounted to the roof of
passenger trains okay and accelera is
actually powering the world's first
Hydrogen fueled commercial passenger
train in operation in Germany in German
we've already delivered already uh over
40 trains we have another 10 that are
being delivered later this year and then
several next year as well so our
European Fleet will actually be very
substantial in size right just this
summer here in Canada up in Quebec we
ran a demonstrator train for three
months from June just until the end of
September when it when it uh concluded
from uh Quebec up to
charlab and it was the first North
American passenger train powered by
hydrogen Fuel and the reason we wanted
to do this demonstration project which
is also in partnership with our key
customer in Europe allam trains is to
show the marketability and the
capability of hydrogen propulsion
technology across different environments
and different Duty Cycles and one of the
things that made that demonstrator
project really unique was that it
encompassed the whole end to-end
hydrogen ecosystem the hydrogen that was
powering that train was created by an
electrolyzer purchased by another one of
our partners haroa energies exceller was
able to provide the electrolyzer which
generated the hydrogen which then
powered the the hydrogen fuel cell train
the train we brought to Quebec is one of
the test trains that we had for the the
testing campaign for the first
generation because we wanted to make
sure we actually demonstrate uh its
operability here in North America the
feedback has been great and frankly
passengers but also we've had a lot of
delegations international delegations
coming having interest in the train
governor of Massachusetts and vernont
and uh and Maine came to actually tour
the train and everyone realizes that
first it's real it actually carries
passengers it's smooth it's very quiet
it's an enjoyable ride so we've had
tremendous
feedback
[Music]
to get a closer look at acceler
electrolyzers Alex Celli the company's
managing director for hydrogen
Technologies walked me through an
assembly area he tells me one of these
machines uses about 5 megaw of input
power and produces about two tons of
hydrogen per day so that would be to put
in perspective would be enough to to uh
rent about 60 buses like on the type of
Transit application for a day okay um
but then you have some customers that
want sometimes three four five of these
machines um the you know one uh customer
that we have very ke up in uh beur uh
north of Quebec yeah has actually four
of these machines and um you know
they're basically using it for for
industrial gas production but that's
that plant has been running for almost 3
years now it's actually the largest pen
plant operating in the world today who
are your primary customers who who who
is buying these in the short term a lot
of the you know the industrial gas
companies the merchant gas companies you
know folks like air liid Lindy Air
Products um but we also have uh you know
also done a few projects with uh you
know folks on the power generation space
so the first five units that we produced
out of here they're in the process of
being commissioned at Florida Power and
Light okay and they're going to
basically be producing green hydrogen to
decarbonize power production so they're
going to blend some of this hydrogen in
a combined SE turbine that today uses
natural gas they'll start blending
hydrogen uh to decarbonize you know
electricity production we also have sold
quite a few of these uh some of these
semiconductor plants that are being you
know insured back into the US uh you
know from the chips act hydrogen is one
of the gases you you require to produce
chips and then uh you know more recently
there's a lot of interest in E fuels so
if you think about sustainable aviation
fuel uh
ethanol ammonia all the way from you
know smaller projects to very large
projects you know for that type of
application the the beauty of hydrogen
you know if if you think about it's it's
very versatile molecule right because it
can be used as a fuel for Mobility but
then it can also be used as an energy
carrier um you know so if you want to
move you know molecules from North
America to Europe s of help uh with some
of the energy crunch that Europe is
going through you can also use hydrogen
for that so with all of its potential
what are the remaining obstacles for
green hydrogen to be more widely used
one significant factor that accelera
plug power and other hydrogen companies
are waiting on is a production tax
credit for clean hydrogen in section 45v
of the inflation reduction act in
particular they're waiting for the US
Treasury Department to clarify
guidelines on what forms of hydrogen
fuel will qualify as clean and low or no
carbon enough to receive a tax credit
the cleanest methods of hydrogen
production would qualify for up to $3
per kilogram but if the guidelines are
made too lenient there is a fear that
less clean hydrogen production could
create millions of tons of greenhouse
gas emissions and undermine the cleanest
hydrogen producers another factor to
consider is the US Energy Department's
recent designation of seven hydrogen
hubs across the country that will share7
billion in Government funding and $43
billion in commitments from companies at
Plug Power I asked the company's VP of
electrolyzer Technology Court middl stat
for his thoughts on hydrogen's future
what do you think needs to happen and
what's going to happen to sort of build
out the hydrogen economy and make it a
more widely used energy source in in a
range of applications beyond what it's
going into today yeah absolutely that's
a great question and and what will
happen and what it comes down to is the
cost of course it's it's absolutely the
the cost so so originally we you seeing
the the hydrogen where plug was able to
find a niche uh uh for hydrogen right
from the beginning was uh for the fork
lift trucks so there even electrolysis
can be competitive right now because the
the hydrogen has to be at high pressure
and it has to be very very pure to
operate in a a fuel cell so in in that
smart that small Market we we can
compete uh today we're getting uh as our
costs come down we're getting the the
next area um that that's willing to pay
a little bit of a of a price premium is
hydrogen as a chemical not hydrogen as a
fuel but what's also coming down what uh
what affects us even more than our cost
is the cost of the renewable energy
renewable energy as you know solar and
wind those costs continue to come down
and down so for instance if in some
areas the cost of solar is as low as 2
cents a kilowatt hour now it takes 50
kilowatt hours to make one kilogram of
hydrogen and 1 kilogram hydrogen is
about the equivalent of a of a gallon of
of gasoline so again you you get that
the green um solar hydrogen for 2 cents
a kilowatt hour and uh and you use uh 50
Kow hours to make a kilogram of hydrogen
so you can see how quite quickly we can
get under $2 uh for the the cost of a
kilogram of hydrogen the department of
energy has a goal for to get all the way
down to $1 and and and at a dollar we uh
we are uh competitive in so many areas
uh and that's why you see the enthusiasm
for hydrogen so high
now certainly one of the challenges is
understanding the adoption curve
understanding the demand and how fast
that will grow and I think the factors
that are affecting that adoption are
price of hydrogen and infrastructure so
availability so the customers aren't
going to say order a th000 trucks if
they don't have a fueling station for a
th000 trucks right so so infrastructure
is one of the the main challenges the
other is cost right now the material to
make fuel cells and the other parts of
the uh fuel cell electric vehicle are
still a little bit expensive and so
there's a there's a cost premium over a
diesel and even over a battery electric
but that cost is coming down and that's
partly what we're trying to do is get
that cost down and so when the cost
comes down uh and the infrastructure is
available then the TCO we call it the
total cost of ownership for our
customers will make sense and they'll be
able to um basically replace their whole
fleets with fuel cell electric trucks
there are still a number of things that
need to happen to make that a reality in
North America on the infrastructure side
production of hydrogen for example is
high on the
agenda uh across US and Canada but
Investments have to be made to really
produce hydrogen green
hydrogen is better obviously it's coming
from renewable uh
electricity um and then there's uh
discussions that have to happen around
distribution of hydrogen uh the network
and stuff like that and then uh the
incentivization of that kind of
initiatives against keeping kind of the
old diesel trains we have in North
America
27,000 diesel locomotives and the
territory is pretty much not electrified
1% of the tracks are actually covered by
catenaries and that's to be compared to
60% in Europe so there's a huge Fleet
which needs to be replaced at some point
and there's a very low electrification
rate so in Ence that could be really uh
a perfect match to uh trains like that
which are basically running without
cener at zero emission but there's a lot
of things that need to happen and um
some states are moving faster than
others but definitely something that
we're watching and we want to mature the
technology and make it fit for the
conditions that uh we have in North
America the long distances the big
freight trains for example require a
specific uh design that we're still
maturing
clearly there's still a lot more that
needs to happen before green hydrogen is
as present in our lives as gasoline or
batteries as other large economies such
as Japan and Australia set their
strategies for competing in the hydrogen
space the us will have to make sure it
can ensure its role as a major player
and the decisions it makes now
particularly around how to define clean
hydrogen could determine future jobs
pollution levels profits and whether or
not America will hit its net zero
emissions targets by